how did someone who gets so much basic
chemistry wrong discover such a
breakthrough unique first of their kind
formulation you might have seen matter
of fact on your social media lately
they're a skincare brand their style
product is a vitamin c serum and they've
been doing a lot of sponsorships with
influencers particularly the ones that
come across as sciencey you might have
been surprised to see me in one of their
influencer ads recently i was surprised
too because no one asked me and three
months earlier i told their founder
exactly why i didn't want to do a
sponsorship with them or endorse them in
any way so today i'm interrupting our
regular viewing schedule to talk about
how matter of fact annoyed me enough to
pause the endless list of content
that i'm meant to be working on to spend
literal days making this video
have you noticed that skin care science
has gotten really trendy for us as
skincare users it makes sense we want to
use products that actually work and
understanding the science behind how
products work is a really good way of
going about it you can find out what
does and doesn't matter so you can focus
on which products actually make sense
for your skin and your life and learning
science is just kind of fun i think
skincare science really got trendy with
the ordinary suddenly we all had a
reason to learn these complex ingredient
names because each product cost less
than ten dollars and while that was cool
i really liked that we all found each
other and got to nerd out together it
also meant a lot of brands saw this and
started thinking hmm how do we get in on
this
bed what are you doing like and
subscribe to help me buy a lock for my
room look using size to sell products
isn't anything new on one level it makes
perfect sense if a brand has invested a
lot of time and money into making sure
their product works well then explaining
to people how it works showing them all
the testing they've done is a really
great way to show people why they should
choose that product and if science is
really trendy then people are more
interested in the details and the brand
can show more of the data that they
normally wouldn't which is great for me
i'm really nosy but science is hard you
have to study and do lab classes and
learn stuff and read papers properly or
if you don't want to do that then you
have to hire scientists and they take
ages to do stuff plus you have to pay
them the whole time why did it take 300
years to get just one number there i did
that in like five seconds so what if we
just
and that's where science washing comes
in science washing is where you take the
aesthetic of science and make things
look scientific without actually doing
the science part things like talking
about studies that aren't interpreted
correctly
citing studies that aren't relevant and
hoping no one looks into them using
scientific words to try to sound smart
but using them incorrectly using numbers
and graphs that don't really make sense
you get the science cred without
actually having to deal with the rest of
the iceberg
and it makes a lot of sense from a
profit perspective mathematical and here
we come to matter of fact who are one of
the most science wash brands i think
i've ever seen
matter of fact is a skincare brand that
claims to be moving the science of skin
care forward with evidence-based
breakthrough technologies their star
product is a vitamin c serum that they
say is the most significant advancement
in skin care in nearly two decades with
unmatched stability potency and cosmetic
elegance this is a big deal because
vitamin c is an incredible skincare
ingredient but it breaks down very
quickly in products their founder is
paul beck their launch email describes
him as a true multi-hyphenate with
degrees from harvard and wharton his
degrees are in psychology and business
and a successful kpop career on his
resume he also worked for two years in
venture capital which he doesn't mention
much he was also mentored in cosmetic
formulation specifically in
multi-technology he says he first got
behind a bench in 2018 but in a few
short months he had already made this
20-year breakthrough in chemistry
without any proper chemistry training
except his mom has a chemistry phd that
keys coming up he outsmarted all of the
thousands of qualified scientists in the
cosmetics industry and his discovery
wasn't even an emotions the thing he was
mentored in foreshadowing amazing that
explains why his press release says he
has a rare yet brilliant mind for both
science and art
i first noticed matter of fact when i
saw the hype around their launch in
september 2021 their ads made some
really bold claims about their ascorbic
acid serum it has unmatched stability in
the vitamin c space the ascorbic acid
was fully stabilized since i am a
massive vitamin c nerd i was really
curious here's that graph showing the
stability of their formula versus the
current gold standard with regard to
stability so the obvious question is
what product are they comparing it with
well it seems like it has to be the
skinceutical c ferulic it's the only
vitamin c product anyone calls the gold
standard but it isn't the gold standard
for stability it's the gold standard for
effectiveness on skin c ferulic is
water-based and water-based vitamin c
serums have a serious disadvantage when
it comes to stability because water
makes ascorbic acid decompose faster
matter of fact actually mention this all
the time so they're comparing their
waterless vitamin c serum to a
water-based vitamin c serum which is a
different less stable category of
product it's a bit like saying ronnie
baker beat the gold standard caleb
dressle so he's unmatched in the hundred
meters and then you realize ronnie baker
is a sprinter and kayla dressler is a
swimmer caleb and the water-based
formula are both fighting against extra
water i'm pretty proud of that analogy
so this is really not good evidence for
showing that your product is more stable
than every other product on the market
so i mildly pestered them about what
data they have for their unmatched
stability claim paul eventually replied
to my email six weeks later we had a
two-hour meeting where we talked about
the brand and the studies they'd done
and he confirmed that the other theorem
in the graph is water-based he said they
tested against three products in total
two water-based and one water free i
don't think you need to know that much
about science to know that if you test
against just three products and only one
of them is in the same category as yours
that doesn't tell you that your product
is the best out of all the thousands of
products out there especially since you
don't know how long those other products
have been sitting on the shelf breaking
down and turning into stuff that can
make a breakdown faster and based on the
science you wouldn't really expect this
to be the most stable product for
example there are silicone-based vitamin
c products like this one from the
ordinary a lot of these use a raw
material called granactive aa20 which
claims to be 90 stable for three months
at 40 degrees in an open container to me
as a chemist it seems incredibly
unlikely that ascorbic acid dissolved in
propane dial can compete with that
propane dial is a humectant moisturizer
and that is really good at absorbing
water so if you put this in an open
container with any amount of humidity
it's going to absorb water from the air
that means even if you start off with
pure propane diol with no water
you're going to end up with propane dial
and water and that water from the air is
going to make the ascorbic acid
decompose a lot faster the propane dial
is basically moisturizing the ascorbic
acid silicone is the opposite silicone
can form a waterproof layer around the
ascorbic acid which protects it from
water it's an occlusive and in this case
the silicone is sealing the water out
the fact that this serum has dissolved
ascorbic acid will also make a breakdown
faster the ascorbic acid can move around
a lot more when it's dissolved which
means a lot more will be available to
react compared to when it's in solid
grains in a thick suspension so it
doesn't really make a lot of sense to
say this has unmatched stability in the
vitamin c space
unless you have a lot of very convincing
evidence to back you up all of the
science that we know about these
ingredients so far goes against that
claim so you're going to want to have
very strong evidence to overturn that
testing against just one waterfree
product just isn't going to cut it we
also talked about the rest of their
marketing i only just noticed this but
the inside of the box lid says facts
matter which is interesting considering
well the rest of this video there is a
lot of incorrect science in their
instagram post that i think again
just really seems to highlight that
there's some basic scientific
understanding and just
really caring enough to fact check
missing for example there's this post
about why vitamin c serums turn brown as
they oxidize they say it's because
ascorbic acid turns into erythrulose and
they say erythrolyse is reddish brown i
explained how this wasn't correct in my
instagram stories erythrology isn't
reddish brown and there's no way this
could be reddish brown this is something
we teach in high school chemistry for a
molecule to be strongly colored it needs
to have something in its structure that
can absorb specific colours of light and
this just doesn't have that about a week
after this paul did a live where he
showed the manufacturer's spec sheet
saying that 75 to 80 erythrologe is
yellow to orange again i feel like this
is pretty basic if i have a cup of water
that's not pure water and it's colored
it's not the colorless water making a
colored it's something else in that
glass and in an oxidized vitamin c serum
you have maybe five percent
erythrologist max it's nowhere near
intense enough to be contributing to the
color change like they said when they
fixed the post i also loved that they
mentioned the confusion like they
weren't the ones who were confused
there's also this three-step thing
paul's mentioned it in an interview as
well
but ascorbic acid decomposes through way
more than three steps
plus it turns into tons of different
chemicals not just erythritos i think
this might be because he misinterpreted
one of my blog posts back in 2017 a lot
of people were asking me why vitamin c
seems to stain your fingers people were
worried that it was pigment or something
dangerous happening i found this diagram
in a paper showing ascorbic acid turning
into a bunch of different things
including erythrolyse which is a common
fake tan ingredient this made a lot of
sense because vitamin c stays look and
act a lot like fake tan so i figured it
was probably the erythrolose or some
other similar chemical in the vitamin c
serum causing it so i did a blog post
and i redrew just those three steps from
ascorbic acid to erythrologe to make it
a bit clearer because
this diagram is just too much for anyone
who just wants to know why their fingers
are yellow dammit i linked the paper and
i wrote this little paragraph to clarify
that erythrolog wasn't the only product
there are lots of different products and
there are way more than three steps
involved but i think paul didn't
understand it and he thought what i drew
was everything because it turned into
this so in my meeting with paul he also
said that he's a big fan of my work he
mentions specific blog posts that he
like and even my reddit username i made
a joke that i should maybe invoice him
for all this free advice and he said he
wanted to pay me to make sponsored posts
and also discuss hiring me to work for
matter of fact he wanted me to help them
design experiments to test their
products and check the claims in their
marketing this last part was pretty sus
to me i've been making science content
for a long time i think i'm really good
at communicating skincare science but
i'm not a regulatory expert i'm not a
cosmetic claims expert beyond what i did
in my diploma and the regulatory
certificate that i'm studying there are
scientists who have been working in the
industry for decades whose job this is
why would you hire a skin care science
influencer without the right expertise
for this his reason was that regulatory
and claims people weren't good at
communicating and he wanted someone who
could communicate well but then you
should hire multiple people scientists
are specialized for a reason you can't
hire a biologist to do chemistry you
can't hire a science communicator and
expect them to deal with all of this
very industry specific stuff accurately
and if you are genuinely dedicated to
getting the right information out there
empowering people with science
why would you only start hiring people
to check the science
three months after launching this brand
has 10 million in investor funding they
can afford to do all of these really big
influences sponsorships they should have
plenty of budget to pay a random chemist
a couple hundred a month to just quickly
check their instagram posts before they
go live the fact they don't have this
this just seems to me like really messed
up priorities for a brand that claims
they want to demystify skincare science
so this was a big red flag so i
suggested i could help them with their
science communication but not in a
public-facing way he could pay me a rate
that was much lower than my sponsored
post rate to just fact check their posts
before they went up and then maybe later
down the line i could do public
sponsored content once their content was
something i was more comfortable with
but paul wasn't interested in that and
that seemed to me like
a pretty big indication that what they
really wanted was to use me and my
reputation to get them to look good and
scientific rather than caring about
actually being scientific and putting
out accurate information they wanted the
veneer of credibility without doing any
of the hard work to earn it so i said if
you wanted to be a scientific brand that
i'd feel comfortable endorsing they
should fix three things firstly fix
their stability claims because they
didn't have the data to make those
claims secondly actually fact check
their post properly before posting so no
more of this erythrologe kind of thing
if you genuinely want to educate people
but you're not sure about something then
just don't post rather than misinforming
people just for the sake of engagement
and gaining followers thirdly stop
making drug claims in their posts and
their sponsored posts drug claims are
when you say your product changes the
structure or function of skin rather
than just the appearance or treating a
disease if your product is a cosmetic
and not a drug then you shouldn't be
making these claims this includes
reducing pigment reducing wrinkles
promoting collagen production treating
melasma and it includes linking studies
where your active ingredient does these
drug things i know it kind of seems like
it should be fine to just state facts
but
there are regulations around this
because drugs go through really rigorous
testing to make sure they actually work
small studies aren't enough to back up
these strong drug claims this is the
sort of thing that happens with illegal
drug claims a lot of skin care brands do
make some degree of drug claims but if
you're a brand that claims to be
scientific and ethical and moving skin
care forward then i think you should
really be on top of this and you
especially shouldn't be making the
stronger drug claims that the vast
majority of brands know not to make for
sponsored posts where a brand has paid
an influencer to talk about their
product influencers generally don't know
the difference between drug and cosmetic
claims brands have to sign off on the
final draft of sponsored content before
it goes live so i really think it's the
brand's responsibility to hire a
regulatory consultant and check that all
the claims they're making are above
board a lot of brands seem to think that
if the influencer makes the drug claims
and sponsored content then it's not
their fault but no that is not a
loophole it still counts as the brand's
marketing claims just like with any
regular ad this is in the ftc guidelines
and both the brand and the influencer
are at fault paul agreed that these
would be good changes to make i agree to
have another meeting in the future to
discuss working with them again and i go
off on my merry way feeling
okay i guess about giving free advice to
a brand for two hours but they did seem
to want to do better and hopefully this
would improve the state of
misinformation in skin care and then a
couple months later i go back and check
what happened 4.1 all the unmatched
stability claims are still up 4.2 which
was not making really basic easily
checked mistakes they've now done a post
where they used a reference because yeah
citing things will make us look credible
and sciency but they don't seem to
understand how references work and it
kind of looks like they've never seen a
reference before in their life either
that or they really felt strongly about
leslie doing three people's worth of
work and then after i posted a story
about this they tried to fix it but then
turned her into baumann leslie and then
after i posted a story about that they
tried to fix it again and doubled up the
title it still looks like that by the
way they also put the molecular
structure of retinol in a post because
chemical structures are science but they
chopped off half the retinal molecule
which makes it a completely different
chemical they actually managed to get
rid of the bit that makes a retinol so i
guess this is ready hot tip for brands
if you're going to use chemical
structures to size up your brand's
marketing the bare minimum you should do
is a three second google for the
structure and then instead of owning up
to the mistake they dug deeper and said
you're right our design team made a
stylistic choice to zoom in on half of
the molecule due to its long structure
when we focus grouped it with some of
our audience members they didn't mind
since the molecular structure was
unfamiliar to them i feel like this
should go without saying but you can't
change the way chemical structures work
just because you focus grouped it the
structure is the molecule this isn't
retinol anymore it's like labeling this
as africa because your focus group said
it was fine and on point three they've
now gotten influences to make sponsored
posts comparing their active ingredient
to hydroquinone which is a prescription
drug so i wrote an email to paul on
january 26 about all of these issues and
i still haven't gotten a reply even
though they clearly saw it and went
through and fixed everything i mentioned
well they tried to fix it anyway and
then on march 13 i get tagged in a
sponsored post that an influencer made
for matter of fact it says they advocate
for women in science like me for women's
history month and of course to buy their
products for the women in your life on
the face of it this is kind of like a
nice shout out from the influencer who
didn't know all of this stuff going on
behind the scenes
although it is a bit weird slash against
advertising codes to put someone in a
sponsored post that you're being paid
for without asking them first but the
way influencer sponsorships work is that
the influencer sends the final draft to
the brand and then they sign off on it
before it goes live so matter of fact
would have seen me in the draft post and
approved this after all of these
interactions with them and still without
replying to my email about poor
amputated reti after 40 days also
without checking if they could legally
use someone in an ad without their
consent and even though this isn't an ad
specifically for their products it is
still an ad lots of companies do ads
where they talk about their value so you
can feel good about them and buy their
products and i don't know why matter of
fact thought i would be comfortable
being used to improve their public image
after
all of this
obviously i complained about this and
they eventually took it down after about
two days again without any sort of
communication with me no apology i had
to ask the influencer to contact matter
of fact also they blocked my comments
from showing up in their post which is
amazing advocacy for me i think
i guess the extremely obvious question
we're building up to here is
how did someone who gets so much basic
chemistry wrong discover such a
breakthrough unique first of their kind
formulation how did paul beck whose only
chemistry background is essentially his
mum and his
rare and brilliant mind outsmart all of
the qualified chemists in the cosmetics
industry crack the elusive code and
create the most significant advancement
in skin care in nearly two decades after
just a few months well if you look at
matter of fact's vitamin c patient which
as of now is still pending
it seems like he kind of didn't this is
the breakthrough that paul claims to
have made it just boiled down to is
there a way to dissolve high
concentrations of ascorbic acid in
solvents that are not water that's sort
of where i started and through a lot of
experimentation found a way to do it the
eureka moment was thinking about other
ingredients that were not liquid at room
temperature potentially being
co-solvents
and using that framework allowed us to
sort of create this new technology so
he's saying he's worked out how to get
more ascorbic acid to dissolve without
water you can only get about 12 percent
ascorbic acid to dissolve in propane
diol but if you add urea you can get
over 20 to dissolve
so that's what the matter fact serum
does which sounds really neat but
someone else already discovered this
17 years ago and it isn't like matter of
fact aren't aware of this they reference
them extensively in their own patient
application even without much science or
chemistry knowledge i think it's pretty
obvious that this 2007 patent is about
using urea to help ascorbic acid
dissolve in polyol apart from this which
someone else discovered first i can't
really see what's so innovative or
breakthrough about this formula it has
other antioxidants feralic acid and a
plant extract but every other vitamin c
serum on the market also has
antioxidants the 2007 patent covers
formulas with antioxidants maybe it's
the fact this combination is stable but
testing someone else's discovery doesn't
mean you discovered it it looks like he
might have seen what he thought was a
potential loophole and tried to file a
patent for that the truth 2007 zang
patents listed examples of polyol
solvents that were covered but one of
the patents didn't list one three
propane dial which is the solvent used
in matter of fact matter of fact
mentioned this specifically several
times in their claims i'm guessing zhang
might have left it out because it wasn't
a common skincare ingredient back then
or maybe he just forgot because he did
list it in his other patient and it's
covered under polyols anyway here are
all the polyols that zhang listed in his
patent claim
and here's matter of facts one three
propane diol i'm not a patient attorney
so i don't know if this patent will get
past pending the rule is that patents
need to be novel and not a trivial or
routine advancement on an existing
patent if it's very similar to an older
patient they often decide that it's
covered by the original if this is what
he's claiming to have discovered what's
essentially a typo and i would think
it's covered under the old patent anyway
legality aside this just doesn't seem
much like a eureka moment to me 1 2
propane dial 1 3 propane dial and 1 3
butane dial are really similar chemicals
as you can guess from the names they
used interchangeably in skincare it
really doesn't seem to me that this is a
truly new technology all that paul
actually created it
biggest breakthrough in two decades
seems like a pretty big stretch
so at the end of all of this
is matter of facts formula fully
stabilized with unmatched stability well
i don't think so i was sent these
bottles in december they expire in
august 2023 so i'm guessing they were
made august 2021 and they've already
started going a lot yellower than when i
first got them i talked to someone else
who has sent the products around the
same time and theirs is actually even
more yellow you can see how colorless
they're meant to be in their promo
videos compared to these other products
that i've had for years well you can see
the difference in color and i think
that's because maybe they didn't test
the product properly under real-life
conditions all the data they show for
their stability claims are with
accelerated testing so they kept the
product for 8 weeks at 40 degrees
celsius to approximate what would happen
for 16 months at room temperature things
react faster at higher temperatures so
we use accelerated testing to get an
idea of whether something is likely to
go wrong with the product without having
to wait as long but it's still an
approximation things happen at room
temperature that don't happen at 40
degrees and vice versa all the time and
this is particularly important for
vitamin c its degradation depends a lot
on temperature so accelerated testing is
a lot more inaccurate than normal and
you can't really say that these are
equivalent but matter of fact don't seem
to know or maybe they don't care about
this pretty important caveat they hardly
ever mention it's approximate they just
keep saying it's been tested for 16
months and i think the packaging is
another big issue heat doesn't speed up
how quickly oxygen and water leak into
your packaging the same way it speeds up
chemical reactions this is an airless
pump but most airless pumps aren't
properly airtight in a standard airless
pump which is what this looks like air
can get through the seams and through
the pump dispenser and given how easily
the pump top came off when i opened the
tube a few days ago i'm not really
convinced this connection is tight
enough to keep propane dial free from
water and oxygen and before anyone says
i'm being unfair because i made it
oxidized by opening it up i showed you
the serum from this tube which i don't
know how to open and it's the same color
as the other tubes i have so these
claims of 16-month 24-month stability
aren't really backed up by their testing
again i don't blame influences for this
these are things about vitamin c that i
didn't know five years ago even with a
chemistry phd even though i was so deep
in skincare science i know cosmetic
chemists with decades of experience who
don't know this stuff because they
haven't worked with vitamin c this is
why expertise is specific there's just
way too much information to know
everything at some point you have to
trust what experts say you have to trust
that people presenting themselves as
experts are responsible and self-aware
enough to say when they don't know
something to check with someone who
knows more matter of fact and paul gave
them this info and signed off on their
post
they're meant to know what they're doing
here's the guy who made the biggest
discovery in two decades they're the
brand moving the signs of skin care
forward and empowering consumers and
this is really the root of what's wrong
with science washing people and brands
who pretend to be experts but
continually put out misinformation
because they want to save time or money
or look smart they make us so much
harder for consumers to work out who to
trust and which products to use
i love talking about skincare science i
love that so many more people care about
it now i love that we have a beauty
science nerd community i love that i've
met a lot of really inspiring experts
and science communicators through this
but i can't deny that there was a lot
less misinformation and it was a lot
easier to spot the misinformation before
everyone decided they needed to
sign things up
[Music]
you